it's the day of the pachamama or the
Mother Earth for Andean indigenous
communities in South America
traveled over 1 000 kilometers to the
center of Buenos Aires to protest
against a new constitution in the
northern province of huhui that they say
will endanger their rights
we are here to defend our access to
water the government doesn't listen to
us we need to have the Deeds of our
territories but the governor ignores us
they want to exploit lithium we say no
to lithium and yes to water
the province of kuhu is located in
Northern Argentina in what is known as
the lithium triangle one of the largest
lithium reserves in the world
in the past years many foreign companies
have started to extract what many refer
to as white gold people here have been
marching for days because they're
extremely concerned about the new
constitution in the province that they
believe will make it easier for
multinational companies to enter their
territory to exploit lithium and other
minerals they believe their livelihoods
are addressing
in June the provincial government passed
a new constitution indigenous
communities say the government did not
consult with them about what will happen
in their territories
the government of uhui has suspended two
articles of the Constitution and said
they will revise them to satisfy
indigenous communities these people say
it's not enough
Kia says her people are tired of being
discriminated against and ignored
there are no rights for indigenous
groups in the country they are rights
for argentinians there is a constitution
but not for us
as the people from the Anderson
celebrate the months of the mother earth
indigenous communities from kohui are
convinced this year is about preserving
their territories from a threat they are
convinced will endanger their way of
life
[Music]
Buenos Aires